bien je suis très heureux de vous
accueillir pour ce dernier Jean-Pierre
oui dernier rendez-vous de
l'année le temps explique que nos rangs
soient un peu plus clairsé qu'il le sont
habituellement mais ce que vous voyez là
c'est la partie émergée d'un iceberg
parce que l'important là-bas c'est les
milliers de personnes qui sont derrière
la caméra sur Internet voilà donc ceux
qui sont là sont faits pour
animer et montrer leur attention à ce
que vous allez nous dire Jean-Pierre
Ryou va vous présenter Corine péuchon en
tout cas lancer le débat avec Corine
péuchon qui est
une philosophe tout ce qu'il y a de
brillant agrégé de philosophie docteur
en philosophie
euh autour des questions euh presque
d'ailleurs docteur en philosophie
politique presque c'est oui oui tout à
fait oui j'en connais une autre que je
vous présenterai et donc non ce ceci est
une parenthèse donc ma fille est aussi à
fait exactement elle vient de soutenir
sa thèse à Science Po euh et donc et
donc euh alors le le la la réflexion de
Corine péuchon si j'ai bien compris elle
porte sur cette
articulation contemporaine de ce que
l'écologie apporte ou de ce que
l'écologie
oppose ou de ce que l'écologie enrichit
de la pensée politique classique et
notamment de la pensée au sens
philosophique libérale
euh je rappelle à ceux qui
l'ignoreraient enfin que personne ne
l'ignore ici parce qu'on le dit assez
souvent que le mot
libéral n'a pas la même signification
dans tous les pays n'a pas la même
signification en philosophie et
en une économie de marché voilà pour
simplifier et donc le le l'école
libérale est une des écoles les plus
profondes de la philosophie
politique moderne et cont oraine moderne
en tout cas et donc le la la réflexion
de Corine Peluchon aorté en grande
partie sur ce sujet
sur la politique et la
morale sur l'éthique en politique sur la
philosophie du sujet comme on dit c'est
même le titre de votre de votre thèse un
enrichissement de la philosophie du
sujet et donc cette c'est quelqu'un qui
a approfondi sous l'angle philosophique
je sais pas si la philosophie est un
angle mais en tout cas qui a approfondi
la question une des questions majeures
que notre temps a traité Jean-Pierre
vous voulez lancer le lancer le débat si
j'ai dit des bêtises vous me le direz
hein non mais Corine
Puchon s'affiche un peu n'est-ce pas
mais il faut quand même que vous sachiez
qu'elle
a très récemment fait un tout petit
livre qui s'intitule comment 20
Marianne compte philosophique et
républicain signale c'est chez bourin en
2012 et que là à travers un compte
philosophie et c'est assez rare
aujourd'hui chez chez les philosophes de
se de renouer avec quelques prestigieux
an de renouer avec quelques prestigieux
anciens euh sur cette notion du compte
philosophique et ça ça nous plaît bien
ce qui nous plaît bien aussi chez Corine
péuchon c'est aussi je dirais les les
maîes parce que je pense qu'on peut
peut-être le dire ainsi encore qu'elle a
eu pour tous ses travaux direction de
thèse habilitation et cetera vous les
connaissez tous mais quand même il faut
citer parce qu'ils sont ils sont et de
nos amis et et pour nous ils sont ils
sont très importants dans cette
réflexion sur les lité le libéralisme
les valeurs l'éthique et cetera j'ai
nommé Rémy brag que nous que nous
inviterons que nous inviterons bientôt
qui qui est déjà venu mais qui reviendra
bien sûr pierre Manan que que vous
connaissez Alain Renaud Philippe Renaud
et cetera et cetera vous voyez bien la
le le domaine
couvert j'ajoute que Corine Pelluchon
vient d'être élu brillamment professeur
de philosophie pratique c'est ça c'est
exact philosophie pratique faudra nous
expliquer parce que nous sommes oui
c'est ça c'est nous sommes un peu
saturés de philosophie actuellement
n'est-ce pas avec le baccalauréat
n'est-ce pas il a soi-disant épreuve
rine n'est-ce pas ça fait quand même 8
jours que ça dure cette affaire avec des
philosophes qui remplissent le leurs
Copin sous l'œil des caméras enfin c'est
tout à fait incroyable bref donc comme
François berou
disait vous êtes de ces philosophes je
crois qui ont su tailler leur leur
domaine
en en mêlant en mêlant les les apports
et les interrogations et ça donne le
titre du de votre exposé ce soir que
vous allez nous nous expliciter écologie
politique condition animales et
Humanisme c'est beaucoup n'est-ce
pas non en fait vous êtes vous partez
des questions éthiques appliqué et donc
largement bioéthique et et écologique et
vous appliquez ça aux valeurs instituées
et au aux institutions et ça donne un
mélange de morale de droit et de
politique qui pour nous est est
évidemment tout à fait précieux je crois
qu'il y a pas de meilleur résumé de
votre de vos travaux passés mais ça ne
préjuge pas des travaux futurs vous
l'avez son thème de recherche bioéthique
écologie et philosophie politique
proposition pour un enrichissement de la
philosophie du du sujet parce que c'est
bien le sujet qui est au cœur
voilà on vous laisse la parole cher amis
pour 30 40 minutes enfin temp discussion
temps équ et nous avons par contre un
arrêt absolu à 20h30 al merci beaucoup
pour cette invitation alors donc ça le
la conférence s'intitule écologie
politique condition animal et Humanisme
donc je vais l'introduire et
effectivement ce travail relève de la
philosophie politique
les connaissances scientifiques les
techniques les pratiques médicales sont
le point de départ d'une enquête visant
à déterminer les conditions d'une
législation adaptée sur des questions
qui posent des problèmes nouveaux ou
dont les conséquences sur les relations
sociales méritent que du point de vue de
la méthode on ne s'en tienne pas
seulement à la déontologie ou à des
idées figées sur le bien et le mal
comment penser l'institution des normes
et au-delà produire le juste dans une
société confrontée à des défis comme ce
que pose la éthique et l'écologie mais
c'est la question centrale en effet la
philosophie des droits de l'homme à
laquelle nous devons tendre ne suffit
pas à penser un bon usage de la nature
dont nous faisons partie et qui est
anthopisé et non vierge qui renvoie des
objets hybrides mais dont les ressources
sont limitées ou dont les capacités de
résilience peuvent être menacé de
manière irréversible par nos activités
cela veut dire que la limite de ma
liberté n'est plus seulement l'autre
homme en même temps le changement dans
les styles de vie requis pour euh faire
avancer l'écologie ne peut-être imposé
si bien qu'il faut penser les tensions
existant entre des normes écologiques le
respect de la biodiversité par exemple
et le droit de chacun à choisir son
style de vie son mode de vie qui découle
du principe cher au libéralisme
politique de la souveraineté du sujet et
qui est précieux car il fonde un
gouvernement limité loin d'une réponse
autoritaire donc le cœur de cette
affaire c'est de dépasser le libéralisme
politique classique dont on trouve une
définition assez précise chez John
Stuart Mill dans un livre de 1859
intitulé de la liberté où mil dit qu'on
ne recours à la force coercitive de la
loi que pour interdire les actions
créant un dommage à autrui un réel
dommage et pas seulement une offense qui
veut dire que il y a un partage entre la
morale et le droit tout à fait précieux
car il évite et bien justement une
extrême
moralisation des décisions politiques il
est il est il est évite de confondre la
morale et le droit et il est précieux
pour légiférer par exemple sur des
questions de Meur car il évite donc de
fonder la décision politique sur ce que
ruvenogien appelle la une éthique
maximaliste sur une vision du monde qui
n'est pas généralisable dans une
démocratie il évite aussi de
criminaliser des crimes sans victimes et
donc d'habiller parfois de mots comme
dignité ou autrre des valeurs qui sont
simplement subjectives donc la politique
ne peut-être fondée sur cette
maximaliste qui s'oppose au fait du
pluralisme et qui vaut à faire passer
pour une décision commune ce qui ne
relève que d'un point de vue moral
cependant l'éthique minimaliste qui ne
s'en tient qu'au consentement et qui
prétend que l'on doit s'abstenir de
toute référence aux sources de la
moralité en politique et bien pour s'en
tenir au principe de ne pas nuire à
autrui et bien cette éthique minimaliste
ne suffit pas pour beaucoup de questions
notamment quand on s'interroge sur les
conséquences à long terme de nos
décisions de de l'impact de nos styles
de vie sur les écosystèmes les
générations futures et les autres
vivants et de manière générale elle ne
prend pas en en compte la responsabilité
qui est la notre et qui est bien souvent
dissymétrique c'est assez évident quand
on parle de génération futur dont nous
pouvons affecter les conditions de vie
mais qui n'affectent pas les nôtres de
même le libéralisme classique n'a pas
les moyens de penser les rapports
d'injustice à l'égard des autres espèces
dont nous menaçons la survie par exemple
en actionnant leur habitat en ne leur
donnant pas d'espace enfin il donne
encore moins la possibilité de faire de
la question animale une question
politique j'en parlerai où les
conditions de vie de l'élevage
industriel imposent aux animaux pris
cette fois-ci dans leur individualité
des problèmes qui sont pas seulement des
problèmes de morale renvoyant à notre
cruauté mais qui renvoie au fait que
nous nous octroyons sur eux un droit
absolu alors que le respect de leurs
besoins éthologiques le respect du
besoin des poules destend de leurs ailes
et cetera qui devrait être ce à partir
du quoi Oni construit l'élevage et bien
limite notre droit d'user comme bon nous
sembr des animaux donc autrement dit ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut plus l'éthique
ne peut plus se borner à la règle d'or
ne fais pas autrui ce que tu ne voudrais
pas qu'il te fie autrement dit l'éthique
minimaliste aussi n'est pas aussi
minimaliste que cela hein elle est elle
va de paire bien souvent avec la
valorisation de la liberté défin comme
capacité à faire des choix et en changer
ce qui est une manière de penser l'homme
en SI imaginant qu'il est d'abord
liberté et même qu'il est une liberté
négative et ce critère conduit quand on
s'en sert pour légiférer sur pour
réfléchir aux décisions aux pratiques
médicales et biomédicales et bien ce
critère conduit finalement à accepter à
l'avance et systématiquement toutes les
thérapies toutes les pratiques qui
augmentent la capacité de l'individu à
faire des choix et en changer alors non
seulement le critère du consentement et
donc ce cadre strict du libéralisme
politique que qui consacre la liberté
des uns ne permet pas de garantir la
liberté des autres et l'égalité comme on
le voit par exemple dans l'exemple que
que j'ai pris ou si on imaginait les
thérapies géniques qui peuvent augmenter
entre guillemets les capacités les
performances physiques intellectuelles
ou autrees de sa progéniture et bien
effectivement cela augmente la liberté
de cette progéniture à faire des choix
et en changer mais cela veut dire que
cette Capac cette liberté des un
condamne les autres qui ne voudraient
pas utiliser C thérapies génique à
finalement le faire ou bien à se voir
reprocher par leurs enfants de les
laisser toujours à la traain à l'école
ou dans toutes les activités donc de
manière générale le libéralisme
politique encore une fois auquel nous
devons beaucoup qui consacle la
souveraineté du sujet et surtout les
gouvernement limité où l'État n'entre
pas dans les chambres à coucher et bien
ce libéralisme politique ne permet pas
d'apprécier les pratiques médicales les
pratiques de manière générale qui vont
au-delà qui posent des problèmes allant
au-delà du simple respect des libertés
de la coexistence pacifique des libertés
et ça veut dire que le vocabulaire des
droits de l'homme et même le vocabulaire
de l'égalité et de l'équité ne suffisent
pas à apprécier ces ces questions ainsi
on le voit les champs de l'éthique
appliqué que j'ai mentionné et bien donc
l'éthique médicale biomédicale et la
question environnementale et bien mettre
en question libéralisme mais de
l'intérieur le mettent en question de
l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire que ça s'oppose
à une remise en question qui viendrait
de l'extérieur comme on le trouve dans
la tradition d'inspiration marxiste ici
il s'agit de compléter le libéralisme à
la fois dans ses institutions et à sa
base c'est-à-dire en s'attaquant alors
non seulement aux instances de
délibération et peut-être à la
définition des devoirs de l'État donc il
y a l'idée de reformuler le problème
politique et j'en parlerai quand
j'aborderai la question du contrat
social qu'on pourrait peut-être modifier
mais s'agit aussi de modifier à sa base
c'est-à-dire de toucher la conception du
sujet qui soutend ces théories
politiques du libéralisme et la
conception de la socialité qui est au
fondement du contractualisme aujourd'hui
qui est encore structuré par l'avantage
mutuelle la réciprocité le donnant
donnant si vous voulez l'idée que bon
voilà il faut gérer la coexistence
pacifique des libertés des intérêts
individuels et c'est tout donc l'enjeu
est vraiment de ce travail qui s'est
appelé à un moment l'éthique de la
vulnérabilité qui est pas finalement pas
une éthique mais qui est une philosophie
du sujet et bien c'est l'enjeu c'est
justement de modifier à la fois dans ses
institutions et à sa base ce libéralisme
politique et ce travail c'est
excusez-moi exprimé ou développé dans
deux ouvrages surtout dans l'autonomie
brisée où la Genèse était les les les
champs de l'éthique médicale et dans
élément pour une éthique de la
vulnérabilité où le point de départ
était la réflexion sur la crise
environnementale et alors ce travail
comporte un volet politique et un volet
ontologique donc lié à la réflexion sur
la subjectivité que je vais donc
développer successivement donc en
commençant par le volet politique qui je
crois est la chose qui vous intéresse
peut-être le plus alors ce volet
politique comporte deux branches l'une
sur les conditions de la délibération
notamment comment on délibère comment on
légifère sur des questions notamment
dites de bioéthique qui vont au-delà bah
du problème de liberté et l'autre sur
les modifications institutionnelles
des instances délibératives et les
transformations de la démocratie pouvant
rendre possible entrée de l'écologie et
de la question animal dans la politique
ce que d'ailleurs j'ai exprimé dans ce
compte qui est très fantaisiste est un
peu fou mais bon c'est comme ça de temps
en temps alors je vais reprendre ces
deux questions donc les conditions de la
délibération bioéthique je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure l'enjeu c'est d'éviter deux
écueils l'éthique maximaliste la
fondation de la politique sur une idée
du bien qui ne serait pas généralisable
qui serait celle de Monsieur Intel
mais aussi l'éthique minimaliste qui ne
suffit pas alors le problème c'est de
savoir comment articuler la morale et le
droit mais sans donc fonder sans
cautionner une vision
moralisatrice de quelqu'un donc la piste
que j'ai proposé il y en a plusieurs
mais celle-ci peut-être intéressante est
la suivante il s'agira non pas de dire
si une pratique médicale ou biomédicale
est bonne ou mauvaise en soi au nom d'un
principe un petit peu à priori mais il
s'agira d'examiner son impact sur le
sens des institutions sur les acteurs
différents acteurs et de mesurer sa
compatibilité ou son incompatibilité
avec les valeurs qui soutendent ces
institutions et même avec les idéaux qui
ont tel ou tel sens dans une communauté
donnée on le voit cette démarche ne
s'oppose pas au changement mais suppose
une sorte de réflexion sur soi-même
d'explicitation parfois des de ce qui
euh soutend nos institutions et ça
permet surtout de savoir ce qu'on est
prêt à changer et au nom de quoi
cela peut donner des résultats assez
intéressants par exemple quand on
s'interroge sur le suicide assisté qui
n'est pas seulement une question du
droit à mourir qui n'est pas seulement
lié à la liberté individuelle même si
cette dimension compte et qui a
effectivement une qui qui ne peut pas
être séparé de la réflexion sur son
impact sur le patient B sur la structure
de soins c'est également important quand
on réfléchit à l'éventualité j'en ai
parlé des l'utilisation des thérapies
géniques ou des nanotechnologies tout ce
qui peut permettre de d' un individu où
l'argument n'est pas seulement focalisé
sur la liberté des parents ni sur
l'égalité entre les personnes mais il
s'agit de réfléchir à l'impact par
exemple de cette pratique consistant tu
l'ai dit tout à l'heure à manipuler sa
progéniture l'impact de cette pratique
sur le sens de la parentalité laquelle
désigne comme disait un théologien où il
a mê ouverture à ce qu'on attendait pas
la dimension d'imprévisibilité est
essentielle dans le rapport à nous-même
puisque notre liberté s'exerce aussi sur
un fond d'inconnaiss AB ilité d'une
découverte progressive de soi et c'est
également essentiel dans le rapport
justement à autruie et en particulier à
l'enfant à ître je rappelle ce beau
texte en condition de l'homme moderne de
Anna arent où elle dit que la natalité a
une dimension politique car c'est la
possibilité que quelqu'un de neuf ouvre
un monde nouveau et que c'est peut-être
le miracle contre la routine la promesse
qui sauve le monde de la routine alors
ça veut dire donc que les technologies
les biotechnologies sont pas mauvaise ou
bonne en soi mais elle nous invite alors
non seulement il y a une réflexion
conséquentialiste mais qui est assez
enrichie qui suppose une réflexion sur
ses propres institutions sur les sources
de la moralité qui donnent la moralité
effective et qui se lisent dans ce que
heel appel la moralité effective dans
les lois mais c'est aussi un rendez-vous
avec sinon la métaphysique du moins des
questions classiques de la philosophie
comme celles qui ont trait à
l'imprévisibilité au temps aux limites
et donc à ce qui et derrière la
condition
humaine également l'enquête pragmatiste
est une piste importante sur des
questions difficiles où personne a
priori ne sait quoi faire car cette
enquête permet de conjuguer diverses
approches de la morale aujourd'hui quand
on a affaire à des question difficile
d'une certaine manière il faut conjuguer
les principes le conséquenti la
déontologie la la réflexion
conséquentialiste mais aussi la
réflexion qu'on a qui renvoie à
l'éthique des vertus c'est-à-dire
comment faut-il être pour bien agir mais
tout cela dans un raisonnement
contextualisé et en ayant soin de
construire pour ainsi dire le bien juste
à titre d'exemple moi il metttait je
m'était apparu que cette enquête
pragmatiste était pertinente quand
j'avais réfléchi avec un comité
d'éthique sur le l'éventualité des
prélèvements d'organes sur les donneurs
ayant fait l'objet d'une décision
d'arrêt de limitation de traitement donc
qui ne sont pas en état de mort
encéphalique mais qu'on appelle les
malades éligibles au mastrich 3 l'Agence
de la biomédecine disait go go go fait
faites et nous donnez-nous des outils
pour faire d'autres la la société
savante disait non non non non car on ne
va pas mélanger l'arrêt de traitement et
le prélèvement on comprend pourquoi moi
je m'étais dit mais pour éviter ces deux
écueils c'est-à-dire être
instrumentalisé par des gens qui savent
déjà ce qu'ils veulent faire ou ne rien
faire il fallait donc proposer une
enquête où on suit le parcours d'un
malade chez lequel on a décider d'un
arrêt de traitement raison d'un
pronostic de très mauvais de
récupération de ses fonctions
neurologiques avec l'image cérébrale on
le peut et on évalue l'impact de cette
pratique en définissant pas à pas des
critères d'acceptabilité sur des choses
extrêmement concrètes et des guerres de
fous évitant évidemment les conflits
d'intérêts qui sont énormes dans ces
domaines et évidemment on on conjugue
plusieurs approches le principe
desontologie la séparation des
intentionnalités et des peut-être des
équipes he donc ça veut dire qu'on
narrête pas les traitements pour
prélever mais on se donne quand même les
moyens de d'adopter un point de vue
faillibiliste donc ou on redéfinit ce
qui peut être fait et surtout ce qui ne
doit pas être fait donc voilà bon ce
travail n servit à rien c'est sûr parce
que l'Agence de la biomédecine qui
voulait donc qu'on lui apporte des
choses nous nous a a repris on était
quelques-uns à faire ça suz surtout des
médecins mais moi j'en faisais partie
finalement fait des brouillons des
résumés qui n'avait ni que ni tête et
aujourd'hui il reprennent ce travail
c'est-à-dire qu'on reprend à zéro c'est
aussi l'indice d'un amateurisme à la
française dont il faudra peut-être qui
qui était problématique qui posait
problème majeur on en reparlera
démocratique he mais et qui qui qui est
lié aussi à cette idée que ces questions
difficiles qui sont pas qui demandent un
examen un peu et technique hein et bien
souvent sont les politiques qui arrivent
au pouvoir sans par de ces questions
comme s'il y avait rien eu avant et là
aussi c'est la politisation extrême de
questions qui appartiennent à tout le
monde est un problème alors j'appordte
maintenant la deuxème partie de ce volet
qui délibère dans une société où les de
donné des sciences qu'on le veille ou
non devrait entrer dans la composition
du politique donc il y a l'idée de
reconfigurer le rapport science société
pouvoir mais en même temps d'éviter le
gouvernement d'experts donc en plus il
s'agit de tenir compte de l'incertitude
des scientifiques en matière de risque
de prévision climatique et de faire de
la place aux controverses scientifiques
donc nos politiques disait Bruno Latour
qui est tout à fait intéressant sur cela
sont des cosmopolitiques au sens où les
questions débattues reflètent nos liens
avec les n humains moi j'y ajouterai
qu'elles sont des EAU politiques puisque
les animaux sont toujours là mais j'en
parlerai tout à l'heure mais il y a
certaines données scientifiques et
techniques dont il faut tenir compte et
qui supposeent des lumières de deexpert
mais l'expert est un scientifique placé
dans une situation stratégique de
l'expertise qui implique en plus un
travail interdisciplinaire son rôle est
de présenter un état des lieux sur la
question manière complexe et ce ce ce
rôle se distingue de la la tâche
classiquement dévolue au politique qui
tranche hein qui décide des priorités
hélas bien souvent comme on le voit dans
les schémas prospectifs même de la FAO
donc sur l'alimentation la sécurité
alimentaire les panels d'experts sont
souvent très homogène regroupant des
personnes issues de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et plus rarement ou plus
récemment de petits agriculteurs
porteurs d'une vision de l'agriculture
différentes de celle qui domine dans ces
prospectives et qui limite l'agriculture
la production des aliments en négligeant
son importance dans la préservation des
paysages et en ignorant aussi les
modèles agricole qui présente une
alternative intéressante au modèle
intensif alors donc de même pour penser
la crise alimentaire mondial si vous
vous référez au au au textees de la FAO
bien souvent c'est un discours
productiviste he il faut augmenter la
production alimentaire de 70 % pour
nourrir 9 milliards d'individus en 2050
bon ce cette manière-l devoir loin
d'être objective suppose et est vraiment
associé lié à la composition très
homogène des experts et aussi à l'idée
de leur conception qu'ils se font de
l'objectivité ou toute référence un peu
scientiste ou toute référence au style
de vie aux habitude alimentaire à la
question de l'usage des terres et à la
valeur non instrumentale des terres et
rejeté à l'avance hein or justement pour
régler cette question entre autres de la
crise alimentaire il est clair que ces
questions sont centrales c'est c'est
donné et pas seulement du quantitatif
bref donc on voit là aussi dans ces
débats tout à fait importants dans le
même dans ces cette organisation de nos
jours qui existe du rapport science
société et bien il y a encore pas mal
d'amateurisme qui se traduit par un
écart considérable entre une entre des
rapports et des ressources humaines
énormes et finalement des résultats
médiocres pareil quand on regarde ce que
fait la Banque mondiale pour lutter
contre la déforestation alors ces
dysfonctionnements qui existent à l'
échelle internationale et nationale
joint à la confusion entre le rôle des
experts et les politiques qui attendent
bien souvent un feu vert pour agir en
toute certitude donc il faudrait le
peut-être en oubliant peut-être que
l'essence du politique lié à à justement
la prise de décision même en situation
d'incertitude et bien pourtant ces
dysfonctionnements ne sont pas une
fatalité alors au niveau des instances
politiques sans doute l'innovation que
nous à laquelle nous invite à penser la
crise environnementale et peut-être
détendre le système délibératif afin de
trouver des contrepoid au présentisme
qu'encourage et bien la représentation
exclusive des intérêts immédiats des
hommes actuels la démocratie
représentative qui est la notre née à la
fin du 18e siècle au 19e siècle dans un
contexte démographique économique
écologique tellement différent du nôtre
que on peut envisager que justement il y
a un contrepoid à ce présentisme alors
comment le faire va-t-on faire voter les
cochons et non non non même moi je ne
pense pas cela c'est dire donc il s'agit
de dire alors qu'on va représenter au
sein des instances délibératives les
intérêts des générations futures et des
autres espèces mais ce sont des hommes
qui vont le faire alors parce que le le
le il y a quelles sont les pistes je
pense que comme première piste on
pourrait en formulant le problème
politique et c'est tout à fait important
cela si on prend le Contrat social de
Rousseau là il y a quelque chose à
reformuler on pourrait inscrire au
niveau constitutionnelle la protection
de la biosphère la condition animale son
amélioration au lieu de la reléguer à la
périphérie du politique et la confier au
seul discours de l'indignation et la
prise en compte des intérêts des
générations futures s'il désignait le
nouveau devoir de l'État alors l'état ne
se borderait plus à assurer la sécurité
des hommes actuels ni à concilier leur
liberté leurs intérêts certes ça on
garderait ça mais il y aurait quelque
chose en plus cela reposerait aussi sur
l'idée que l'éthique l'éthique a changé
de sens cela dire ça veut dire et ça ça
fait référence au volet ontologique que
je développerai tout à l'heure plus plus
brièvement he l'éthique n'est pas
seulement une discipline normative me
disant où est le bien et où est le mal
et comment le penser mais elle est une
liée à l'autolimitation elle est liée à
la au droit de mon droit si je puis dire
la place que j'accorde à mon droit à
exister à prendre les ressources de la
les nourritures et à l'idée que je ne
veux pas imposer aux autres espèces et
aux autres hommes une vie
diminuée deuxème piste on peut penser
sinon à représenter les intérêts des
générations futures et des animaux comme
le veut Dominique Bour qui a des idées
tout à fait intéressante un peu fau
folle mais tout à fait intéressante
c'est souvent la même chose dans sa
démocratie écologique on peut du moins
sans aller jusqu'à ces propositions à
lui veiller à la compatibilité entre les
décisions visant par exemple à soutenir
la consom mtion et les normes
écologiques car force c'est de constater
que bien souvent il y a une
contradiction entre des mesures prises
pour soutenir la croissance et des
déclarations d'attention disant il faut
vraiment faire de l'écologie ce qui ce
qui est vraiment un problème politique
d'incohérence qui est majeure la
première vertu en politique c'est
justement la cohérence et pour les lois
c'est pareil le droit disait une juriste
tout à fait Catherine LaBruce rou tout à
fait distinguée le droit c'est comme un
système immunitaire au sens où il y a
des rejets quoi l'idée au niveau
législatif et donc moins de dire le vrai
que d'ordonner d'organiser quelque chose
mais euh on l'a vu il y a il y a souvent
des contradictions alors on pourrait
envisager que des voir des organisations
non gouvernementales ou des personnes
connaissant les questions relatives au
climat et bien euh exerc un rôle de
vigilance dans des commissions régulant
l'énergie l'agriculture le transport le
logement la recherche l'éducation donc
ne siègeant pas au même titre que les
députés mais veillant à cela et cela
garantirait un traitement transversal de
ces questions qui lorsqu'elles sont
traitées de manière atomiste ne peuvent
pas être traité du tout hein comme
justement l'écologie comme la question
animale comme la question de l'quité
intergénérationnelle troème piste on
peut penser ou il faut penser des
contrepouvoirs à la toutpuissance des
lobbyes qui est dans le domaine dans les
domaines dont je m'occupe un problème
central et pour contrer les lobbyes la
confiance dans les représentants est
essentielle hein la confiance ça
s'inspire mais il y a peut-être des
principes qui devraient être
systématiquement appliqués pour
assaignir la vie politique et cela ne
signifie pas qu'il faille demander aux
hommes politiques d'être vertueux hein
faut lire xénophond il faut lire jamais
les hommes politiques n les mêmes vertus
ni que les prêtres ni que les
philosophes il y a une passion propre du
politique et les philosophes dont parle
leostros l'analyse très bien alors ça
c'est une manière de compléter la
démocratie représentative et cela aussi
va de paire avec une participation des
citoyens qui loin d'être un mot magique
suppose une information une formation où
la l'université d'ailleurs aurait un
rôle majeur à jouer qu'elle ne faitelle
joue pas alors cependant en disant cela
et bien je ne règle aucun problème enfin
je ne règle pas le problème majeur lié
au fait que les conflits écologiques
opposant les individus et bien suppose
révèle des positions ontologiques
renvoyant chacun à la manière dont il se
pense dans la nature d'ailleurs John
rolls avait parfaitement conscience que
les problèmes environnementaux ne
pouvaient être résolus sur la base de la
justice procédural et du consensus par
recoupement vous savez où on ne garde
que les opinions qui chevauchent et on
oublie les fondations métaphysiques
pourquoi car ces conflits écologiques
par exemple suppose que l'on supposait
que l'on introduisit des valeurs à
propos desquelles nous ne pouvons pas
obtenir un consensus par recoupement
alors quel piste proposée bien il s'agit
pas de fonder la politique sur un ordre
écologique parce que ça ferait hurler
Luc Ferri donc donc pour ça faut pas
mais il s'agit de penser la place des
conceptions ontologiques dans le débat
politique or ces conceptions
ontologiques ne sont pas forcément
explicites et s'expriment d'abord par
des émotions par jugement esétique
l'idée est de faire en sorte qu'elles
soit explicitée par les participants au
décision politique on intègre ainsi tout
un tas de règles qu'on connaît bien en
politique pour les négociations les
règles de l'éthique de la discussion qui
relèvent plutôt d'un consensus par
confrontation un petit peu plus
substantielle que chez rô la théorie des
parties prenantes qui est très imp
important dans le cadre des conflits
opposant des communautés aux valeurs
différentes bref on intègre aussi tout
ce qui renvoie aux procédures
participatif mais en étant conscient que
ce type de conflit ne sont pas seulement
des conflits d'intérêts mais des
conflits de valeurs et on est conscient
aussi que l'écologie n'affecte pas
seulement les principes de la justice
distributive mais aussi les fondements
de l'éthique et le droit et du droit et
la manière dont on se perçoit dans son
rapport aux autres espèces aux autres et
à la nature et tout cela j'en profite
pour euh pour pour dire que la la
protection animale dans ces débats cesse
donc d'être relégué à la à la périphérie
du politique puisque la question animale
est l' preuvees de notre justice
l'élevage intensif par exemple contre en
contraignant les animaux d'élevage
appelés animaux drantes à s'adapter aux
contraintes de d'un élevage calqué sur
l'industrie au mépris de leurs normes
éthologique et bien suppose nous fait à
croire que nous avons un droit absolu
sur les animaux alors que justement
leurs normes limitent notre droit d'en
user comme bon nous semble et il y a
aussi une réflexion sur l'organisation
du travail à partir d'un chiffre optimal
de rendement qui témoignent d'un dénis
du réel qui se reflète aussi parfois
dans l'organisation du travail des
hommes enfin la la spécificité de mon
approche dans c'est même dans son volet
politique c'est que je me focalise moins
sur le statut moral voire juridique des
objets de la responsabilité que sur nous
c'est-à-dire sur le sujet de la
responsabilité et cela veut dire que mon
travail à la Distin à la différence de
ce qu'on trouve dans l'éthique
environnementale anglo-saxon par exemple
et bien est adossé à une réflexion
relevant de la philosophie première et
que loin d'enterrer l'humanisme suppose
justement de le transformer mais de le
rénover de le reconduire alors j'arrive
donc à au volet ontologique de ma
réflexion qui prendra moins de temps
alors ce volet ontologique est
inséparable de l'éthique de la vulné
habilité que j'ai élaboré et dont la
Genèse remonte à mes premiers travaux en
éthique médicale en effet l'éthique de
la vulnérabilité est né il y a quelques
années d'une interrogation pleine de
perplexité sur l'identité des malades
souffrant d'affection dégénérative du
système nerveux et d'un travail de
reconfiguration la notion d'autonomie
visant à rendre utilisable cette notion
en médecine dans les contextes dans le
contexte éique en effet le fait
d'identifier l'autonomie à
l'autodétermination ce qui marche à peu
près pour nous et bien ne permet pas de
penser l'autonomie d'une personne en
situation de dépendance ce qui sur le
plan politique éthique mais aussi
politique par exemple au niveau de
l'intégration des personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap et problématique
au contraire pour penser l'autonomie
au-delà de la compétence juridique
éviter deux écueils dans la prise en
charge d'une personne dépendante ces
écueils étant systématiquement décidé à
sa place et même une personne atteinte
d'Alzheimer réagit par la prostration ou
l'utre l'autre écueil c'est l'abandonné
à son sort plateau repas hein donc pour
éviter ces deux écueils on peut penser
l'autonomie comme étant une double
capacité la première capacité c'est
celle de c'est le fait d'avoir des
désirs et des valeurs et même de pouvoir
s'estimer soi-même à la réalisation de
certaines activités l'estime de soi ne
disparaît pas même quand on a perdu la
morale ou qu'on a pas la pas la morale
la mémoire o qu'on a plus les mêmes
valeurs la deuxième capacité que désigne
l'autonomie c'est la capacité à traduire
ses désirs et ses valeurs dans les faits
et il est clair que les déficits
notamment cognitifs affectent
profondément cette deuxième capacité de
que désigne autonomie et qui doit donc
être soutenu par les soignants et
aidants lesquels doivent essayer de
comprendre la volonté de la personne
afin d'aller la chercher là où elle est
c'est-à-dire de l'accompagner et de lui
proposer des activités susceptibles de
lui correspondre on le voit au lieu
d'avoir une opposition binaire comme
dans les manuels d'éthique médical qui
répète ce qui se pose aux États-Unis
depuis 40 ans et bien au lieu d'avoir
une opposition binaire entre d'un côté
une autonomie introuvable et de l'autre
côté une bienfaisance médicale
paternaliste on ne met l'accent sur ce
que signifie la responsabilité dans le
contexte clinique et sur les qualités
diverses d'attention de communication
qui sont nécessaire pour ce travail de
même le passage de l'éthique à la
justice envers les personnes en
situation de handicap suppose une prise
en charge individualisée répondant à
leurs besoins spécifiques et cette
remarque souligne si besoin est la
pertinence de l'éthique de la
sollicitude ou éthique du CA cependant
le passage à la justice suppose qu'on ne
s'enferme pas seulement dans le soin et
qu'on ne mette pas seulement le curseur
sur les besoins de soins de la personne
mais que l'on cherche aussi à promouvoir
sa capacité à participer d'une manière
ou d'une autre au monde qu'on essaie de
promouvoir son droit exister d'une
manière vraiment humaine l'approche des
capabilités donc à la suite d'un
martiassen et Martin noosbaum insiste
sur ce que la personne peut réellement
faire sur sa liberté réelle pas
seulement formel et surtout sur ce qui
empêche concrètement une personne
d'utiliser et bien des biens premiers
des choses distribuées donc au lieu de
s'in d'avoir des droits sur le papier on
va insister sur le travail en amont qui
est nécessaire de la part des politiques
publiques et des structures de soins
pour éviter que des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité a seulement
des donc des droits s papier et aent une
vie diminuée ou en raison de leur
déficit handicap et bien elle se voit
privé du droit d'accès au liens social
au développement de le danss émotions et
cetera ce qui doit être égalisé ici ce
sont les capabilités hein ça veut pas
dire que personne en situation de
handicap deviendra danser étoile mais ça
veut dire qu'un déficit de capabilité
dans le développement de de de ces de de
ces émotions et cetera n'est pas
seulement un malheur mais une injustice
cette manière d'articuler l'autonomie la
vulnérabilité puisque qui modifie le
sens de ces notion puisque l'autonomie
n'est plus seulement indépendance et la
vulnérabilité n'est pas seulement
fragilité et bien cela implique une
démarche thérapeutique s'appuyant sur
les promesses de vie demeurer intacte
malgré l'ensemble des
déficits cependant l'éthique de la
vulnérabilité n'est pas réservé aux
personnes vulnérables il s'agit d'une
philosophie du sujet c'est-à-dire
qu'elle désigne une manière de penser le
rapport à soi et à l'autre que soi elle
se fonde même sur une triple expérience
de l'altérité la première expérience
renvoie en effet à la passivité du
vivant de tout vivant mais je le disais
tout à l'heure la vulnérabilité n'est
pas seulement fragile n'est pas
seulement altération du corps qui
sensible à la douleur qui vieillit et
qui donc est qui qui est dans la
passivité hein qui est qui ne qui ne
maîtrise pas tout elle est aussi la
vulnérabilité une force si je puis dire
elle est la capacité à
être concerné voire blessé par ce qui
arrive à l'autre donc aussi être
responsable de l'autre et cela signifie
qu'il y a une altérité en moi si je suis
donc concerné par ce qui arrive à
l'autre et même si je me définis par la
manière dont je réponds à l'appel de
l'autre et cette manière de nommer le
sujet en affirmant la centralité de la
responsabilité sur la liberté ou la
manière dont la responsabilité infléchit
la définition de la liberté et bien je
je la reprends et l'articule à la
3oisème expérience du rapport à
l'altérité et qui renvoie à ma non
indifférence à l'égard des institutions
de ma communauté politique donc tout
cela l'autonomie la responsabilité la
vulnérabilité sont les catégorie
centrale du travail que j'avais fait et
dont l'enjeu était de voir comment on
peut on aboutit à une conception du
sujet dont l'enjeu est de voir comment
on peut modifier les termes du contrat
social alors il s'agit pas seulement de
penser la symétrie bien sûr il SAG ni de
réfléchir au rapport de domination ça a
été fait très souvent notamment par les
féministes ou par les philosophies
sociales s'inspirant de du successeur de
abermas honnête mais pour moi le but
c'était surtout de proposer un autre
concept de sujet qui intègre dans son
vouloir vivre le souci de ne pas imposer
aux autres espèces une vie diminuée et
de faire un bon usage de la nature donc
le sujet ne se définit pas par la
capacité à faire des soix en changer
mais par le rapport à l'autre que soit
et le fait même de nous interroger sur
notre manière d'habiter la terre l'cos
et de nous rapporter aux autres espèces
modifie le climat de la philosophie qui
n'est plus une philosophie purement et
simplement de la liberté ou du pour soi
et encore une fois l'éthique désign ici
la dimension de mon rapport à l'autre
voir aux autres espèces et en avec
l'idée que c'est l'existence des autres
dans leur matérialité qui me met en
question et m'impose de penser des
limites à mon droit d'user de tout ce
qui est bon pour ma conservation alors
ce travail en plusieurs étapes aboutit
au remplacement de l'éthique de
l'autonomie on pourra en parler par
l'éthique de la vulnérabilité à la
promotion d'un humanisme de
l'altérité fondé sur la positivité des
différences et à la construction d'un
concept rigoureux et démesuré en ce sens
de la responsabilité qui affirme la
nécessité d'un changement de culture
politique l'éthique de la vulnérabilité
est un humanisme au sens où c'est en
partant de l'homme et de son rapport à
l'autre que lui qu'on peut proposer une
autre conception du lien social et
envisager un modèle de contractualisme
qui rende compte de notre solidarité
envers les personnes qu'une conception
trop étroite de l'autonomie exclu de la
prise en compte des générations futures
des autres espèces et de la nature donc
il est pas seulement en question
d'étendre notre responsabilité à
d'autres qu'à mon prochain mais
fondamentalement de penser l'accent est
plus sur le sujet un concept de sujet
qui rend possible une aut organisation
sociale et politique alors ayant
commencé d'abord par la
passivité euh enfin par une philosophie
de la corporéité car c'est bien ce sujet
corporel mais plus que ça la corporéité
du sujet c'est pas seulement le fait
d'être mortel ou d'avoir un corps c'est
la contestation du privilège comme dit
les Vinas qu'on accorde à la conscience
de de donner un sens à toute chose hein
donc ayant commencé par une philosophie
de la corporéité du sujet qui mettait en
avant la passivité j'insiste aujourd'hui
sur la catégorie de jouissance ce que
les vinac aussi appelai les nourritures
dont on vit dont on jouit mais qui ne
tomb pas toute seule et dont il s'agit
de penser le partage et dans un travail
en cours de rédaction je cherche
justement à mettre au jour des
structures fondamentales de l'existence
ou le fait de vivre deux de manger la
notion de lieu d'habitation sont prises
au sérieux un chapitre important et est
consacré à l'acte de nourrir qui est
tout à fait paradigmatique car cet acte
à la fois biologique et social intime et
collectif moral et politique témoigne
d'un dépassement du dualisme nature
culture et surtout l'éthique ici devient
mon rapport aux autres hommes passés
présent et àenir et aux autres vivants
par les nourritures mais il y a d'emblé
dans mon rapport à l'altérité des
nourritures et dans la manière dont je
mange une position ça relève déjà de
l'éthique c'est une position dans
l'existence je m'en explique mais bon
donc les nourritures ici désignent pas
seulement les aliments mais le milieu
naturel et culturel dont je vis et cela
implique une réflexion sur le milieu
humain le lieu sur la géographicité de
l'aide qui est riche en insignement sur
la manière dont nous aménageons l'espace
cohabitons avec les autres espèces et
organisons l'agriculture devrions
cohabiter avec les autres espèces
organiser
l'agriculture donc là aussi ce qui
pourquoi l'alimentation est importante
dans ce travail pourquoi est
paradigmatique parce que justement on
affirme ici la dép endance de sujet à
l'égard des conditions matérielles de
notre de son existence et on prend en
fait au sérieux ce qui vient avant la
liberté mais dans cette démarche
l'écologie loin d'être exilée hein pour
des et bien elle est intégrée à une
philosophie de l'existence elle est
articulée à l'existence elle est placée
au cœur de l'existence et c'est
peut-être ce qui en soulligne mieux sa
centralité donc cette phénoménologie des
nourritures qui est donc relève d'une
philosophie première et bien joue euh le
rôle que jouait dans le contrat social
de HS ou de Rousseau l'état de nature la
fiction de l'état de nature et l'idée
c'est justement de rénover le contrat
social pourquoi et bien parce que de HS
à Rols et bien vous avez euh la la
socialité le lien social est structuré
par l'avantage mutuel la réciprocité ce
qui pose un problème d'ailleurs sur la
question du rapport aux personnes
handicapées et à Marty Hassen avait
d'abord mis fait une critique à rolls
là-dessus hein les féministes aussi mais
parce que mais le fondement aussi du
contrat social c'est le sujet pour les
droits de l'homme c'est pareil considéré
comme un agent moral individuel et
indépendant or à partir du moment où on
veut faire entrer l'écologie et la
question animale dans la politique
démarche classique pour l'instant en en
en écologie politique et en éthique
animale mais surtout à partir du moment
où on défend cette phénoménologie des
nourritures qui pointe une autre un
autre sens de l'existence à même notre
rapport au lieux et tout ça alors on a
besoin de penser autrement en contrat
social puisque on aura non seulement une
conception une ontologie une conception
qui implique une rel une conception plus
relationnel du sujet on pensera le
rapport aux générations futures mais
plus précisément on on va plus
reconstruire l'association civil à
partir du jeu des égoïsmes et en vue de
la seule conciliation des libertés et
des intérêts sécurité liberté non
domination prospérité mais on va
construire l'association civile à partir
d'un sujet qui est déjà dès qu'il mange
en rapport avec les autres hommes passés
présent et futur et les autres espèces
et qui dans ces gestes les plus
quotidiens encourage telle ou telle
distribution telle ou telle production
telle ou telle agriculture tel ou tel
élevage et telle ou telle économie ce
qui fait que la responsabilité personne
y écha donc je finirai pardonnez-moi
j'essaie de faire signe à quelqu'un au
fond
agès je vous prie de m'excuser je vous
en pris donc je je je disais que quand
je parle de modifier le contrat social
il s'agit pas de dire que nous passons
un pacte avec la nature ni avec les
animaux mais c'est un Pact entre les
hommes d'ailleurs que chez Michel ser
aussi c'est un Pact entre le contrat
naturel est un contrat social entre les
hommes mais en plus de la conciliation
des libertés des intérêts individuels le
problème politique auquel le pacte
social devrait répondre suppose la
considération d'autres objectifs liés
aux conditions de notre existence et ces
objectifs ne se born pas à la
préservation des ressources de la Terre
mais ils sont formulés de telle manière
que la préservation de la nature est
intégrée au soucis que nous avons de
notre existence et que l'écologie est
placée dans le cadre d'une réflexion
plus large sur la culture le respect des
animaux l'amélioration de leurs
conditions et la préservation d'un monde
habbitable sont au cœur du contrat
social car ils entrent dans la
définition du sujet de l'être au monde
alors juste pour conclure je dirais que
tout cela suppose des transformations de
la politique voire des passions
politiques puisquon est plus dans les
oppositions idéologiques traditionnelles
qui ne permettent plus d'apprécier ces
questionslà et au-delà de la question de
l'autonomie politique et de ce qu'elle
requiert à la fois sur le plan de la
formation et au niveau
organisationnel on
doit affronter un problème soulevé de
manière très profonde par Rousseau dans
le contrat social que je vais citer il
dit pour qu'un peuple naissant puis
goûter les scènes maximes de la
politique il faudrait que l'effet F pu
devenir la cause que l'esprit social qui
doit être l'ouvrage de l'institution
président à l'institution même et que
les hommes fussent avant les lois ce
qu'ils doivent devenir par elle alors
cette circularité explique aussi qu'il
faille réfléchir à l'opinion qui avec
les meurs les habitudes les coutumes je
cite Rousseau garde un peuple dans
l'esprit de sa constitution et qui
fondent le sens de l'obligation c'est
pourquoi il y a vraiment on ne peut pas
me semble-t-il faire trava donner
fournir une réponse démocratique au
défis écologiqu entre autres sans pas
s'adosser à une philosophie du sujet et
euh donc en un mot la période que nous
vivons pousse à l'innovation même remet
peut-être sur euh soulligne l'actualité
jamais démenti des lumières il a un
retour aux lumières après la critique
des lumières où le mot de Kant sa pé à
odé que je faisais dire à un de mes
chats puisque moi j'adore les chats donc
je je faisais transformer les les les
philosophes en chat dans le compte c'est
pas grave mais donc où le mot de Kant s
périt à odé penser par toi-même toujours
d'actu é donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que il y a l'idée
dans d'innovation politique qui doivent
aussi passer par ce que
castoriadisaelait la promotion d'une
création imaginaire mais tant au centre
de la vie humaine d'autres
significations que l'expansion de la
production et de la consommation
etposant des objectifs différents qui
puissent être reconnu comme valant la
peine cette création imaginaire
permettant de faire le lien entre la
théorie et la pratique la philosophie
l'action sans qu'elle s'appu dit sur une
adhésion à la fois ou à des valeurs qui
ne sont pas qui ne peuvent pas être
imposé ni sur une vision moralisatrice
et discriminante des choses je vous
remercie
pardonnez-moi c'était un exposé très
savant très nourri très
construit euh et donc euh
euh c'était c'était très stimulant euh
euh dans tous ces chapitres alors on va
essayer de les aborder tous donc euh
tout ce qui touche à
euh la condition
animale et à la condition animale pour
nous êtres humains qui vivons de
manger euh on va prendre une première
série de questions sur ce sujet si vous
voulez bien si ça vous intéresse
euh et après on passera à une deuxème
série que nous avons déjà abordé dans
cette salle et dans cette instance qui
est l'introduction de l'intérêt des
générations à venir dans la décision
politique je vous rappelle que c'est un
sujet que nous avons traité lorsque nous
avons voté le projet humaniste
euh et donc qui veut parler de la
condition animale et des questions que
ça pose enfin vous êtes libre de vos
questions
d'ailleurs oui très
bien non ben allez-y alors puce que je
me fais interdire à juste titre de
guider les questions donc il n'y a
qu'une règle on va alterner masculin et
féminin si vous voulez bien
oui euh bonsoir et merci beaucoup pour
votre exposé vous avez mentionné au
début enfin justement dans la première
partie une question sur enfin un point
sur la condition animale et j'ai pas
très bien compris vous avez dit ce
serait intéressant de pourquoi pas le
mettre dans la Constitution enfin est-ce
que vous pourriez revenir dessus parce
que je vois
pas pourtant en tant que que
végétarienne je suis assez attaché à la
condition animale mais je vois pas
trop quel plus ça aurait de l'introduire
dans la Constitution alors d'abord je
vais répondre à votre question en disant
pourquoi me semble-t-il il faudrait
l'introduire d'abord ben si si il y a un
si la si la les violences infligé aux
animaux notamment dans l'élevage
industriel mais pas seulement nous nous
concerne nous blesse parce que elle nous
renvoie une image de nous-même qui aussi
peut être insupportable si elle
trahissent l'injustice de notre droit le
fait que nous octroyons un droit absolu
que nous n'avons pas
euh alors ça veut dire c la question
animale est une question politique si en
plus nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à ne
plus accepter euh ce que l'on fait les
souffrances intolérables qu'on que
chaque année on inflige aux animaux
alors cette question ne peut pas être
seulement morale ou liée à bien voilà il
y a des gens qui sont un peu méchants
qui mettent les voyez qui mettent les
les Tru gestantes dans des cages mais
elle doit avoir elle doit être euh au
cœur de la République hein comme le
voulait Victor Hugo et tout ça et elle
doit euh être un devoir de l'État alors
ça veut pas dire imposer le végétarisme
parce que le végétarisme il y a un
végétarisme militant qui est une
réaction contre ce qu'on inflige
aujourd'hui aux animaux par eu mais le
végétarisme philosophique et nous fait
traverser les frontières de la justice
parce que c'est vraiment la question de
qui suis-je pour m'autoriser à faire
couler le sang des bêtes pour me nourrir
et là on est dans quelque chose qui euh
hélas ne peut pas va être imposé en tout
cas politiquement mais il y a voyez là
il y a mais la la question de
l'amélioration de la condition animale
et d'autant plus une question politique
que non seulement la les lois les
directives européennes sont ne sont pas
respecté la plupart du temps quand la
question du bien la question du
bien-être et souigne le fait que le
droit est piégé hein puisque le pour les
poule pondeuse bah le progrès c'est à
peu près l'équivalent de la cage il y a
à peu près ça de progrès hein
l'équivalent d'une carte postale ou un
peu plus ça c'est super comme progrès
euh pour le bien-être animal ça montre
que le bien-être animal est une notion
qui à l'origine était intéressante et
qui est complètement piégée et euh et
l'idée là aussi une question importante
parce que là encore le droit doit venir
après au sens où il faut peut-être
d'abord insister pour qu'on le plus dans
plus de monde de personnes euh fassent
entrer dans la sphère de la
considération morale les animaux qui ne
compent pas pour rien donc voà voilà
donc mais je pense que le mettre alors
là dans la Constitution ça fait que là
la question animale est une question
politique est aussi c'est le refus aussi
d'une civilisation qui impose ces
traitements là et qui peut nous faire
honte en tout cas moi je le
pense fondamentalement et les politiques
sont très silencieux sur cette
question trop silencieux sur cette
question peut-être
alors c'est bien que vous finissiez sur
ce point parce
que moi j'ai constaté depuis des années
que je fais de la politique que ce sujet
la protection animale la défense animale
est un tabou on n pas le droit d'en
parler dans la classe politique
française
et alors ma première question c'est
d'abord comment vous analysez
ça en
France comment vous analysez cela en
France et plus globalement dans les pays
latins ou de de tradition latine et
pourquoi dans des pays plus anglo-saxons
de tradition plus anglo-saxon ce sujet
est incontournable dans la vie politique
j'aimerais comprendre ça c'est un sujet
un sujet qui qui m'a toujours préoccupé
encore récemment j'aichangé avec une
députée dont je tirais le nom c'est pas
la peine de le dire ici qui investi sur
la question de la protection animale et
qui à l'Assemblée nationale se confronte
toujours au même sarcasme au même
sourire en coin sur ce sujet-là qui
n'est pas jugé sérieux au mieux au pire
jugé comme un un sujet trop porté par
des gens infréquentables hein l'extrême
droite en général encore récemment je
lisais dans le journal à propos qui me
désolait enfin pas un propos enfin un
constat qui me désolait que euh
les les jeunes gens qui ont euh tué un
jeune militant d'extrême gauche étit
pour la fille en tout cas militante de
la cause animale les gens d'extrême
droite qui sont dans dans la quiit dans
la cause animale ou alors c'est
permanent ce rapprochement qui est fait
entre l'investissement la protection
animale et des idéologies d'extrême
droite mais ça c'est vrai en en en
France plutôt hein et puis bon brigitte
bardau a beaucoup fait de mal à à à ce
sujet et il y a moi aussi ce parallèle
que je comprends pas entre une une une
impossibilité d'aborder ce sujet c'est
une réponse à votre dernière
interrogation les politiques sont muets
parce que c'est un un sujet qui est
difficile de porter en France et
pourtant moi j'ai constaté que les rares
fois où je l'ai abordé dans des meetings
dans des réunions publques a beaucoup de
monde qui venit me voir après pour me
dire c'est bien que vous l'z aborder on
'entend jamais parler c'est un sujet qui
pourtant n'est pas si anecdotique que
cela si on sort un petit peu du Chacha à
mémer et cetera c'est qu'il y a des
sujets beaucoup plus graves et beaucoup
plus intéressants tels que vous les avez
évoqué tout à l'heure alorsling a été
comme vous savez secrétaire général des
ver au sein des vequel je n'ai jamais pu
défendre cette idée
ça c'est parce que c'est par ailleurs
aussi un un sujet qui est jugé comme
secondaire sans intérêt et qui en gros
les animaux c'est les espèces à protéger
biodiversité la biodiversité mais c'est
pas l'individu animal qu'on fait
souffrir et qu'on devrait considérer
comme un individu qui à qui on peut pas
faire touer n'importe quoi comme un
objet oui merci pour cette question
alors je sais pas pourquoi moi je verrai
quelques pistes d'abord il est vrai que
les personnes qui qui se font les
défense qui sont qui défendent la
question animale souvent sont extrêmes
c'est vrai parce qu'ils ils ont des
hîoséthiques par exemple condam vouloir
l'abolition de l'expérimentation animale
c'est pas sérieux quand on sait le
progrès rechercher le cancer et cetera
dû à l'expérimentation animale après il
y a la manière de le faire donc il y a
des choses il y a un discours
abolitionniste qui est parfois excessif
et qui ne prend pas en compte d'autres
intérêt d'où ces îos éthiques qui
caractérisent même les philosophes qui
travaillent sur l'animal et qui le font
aussi d'un point de vue donc non
humanisme comme s'il fallait choisir
entre la condition sociale ou les
humains et les animaux la protection
animale donc ça c'est le premier écueil
mais ça vient de de leur de leur faille
si je puis dire la deuxième je crois que
quand
même la question de prendre en
considération l'animal prendre tirer les
conséquences dans nos pratiques de ce
que les éthologues nous disent depuis
déjà quand même longtemps hein puisque
nous savons tous que les animaux sont
pas des machines et bien c'est
évidemment un changement tel au niveau
de l'économie au niveau de
l'organisation il y a aussi des lobes
quand même bon que ça ça ça ne peut que
demander du temps et je crois que comme
ça jeter ça dans le débat politique de
de manière brutale ça serait
contreproductif c'est une question
tellement importante qu'elle nécessite
de la ruse aussi et du temps et maisi la
Constitution d'abord ben donc donc
l'idée que parler des animaux c'est nous
regarder dans un miroir que c'est donc
voilà c'est il y a ça c'est vraiment et
que ce puis on voit bien de toute façon
on voit bien nous nous sommes nous avons
l'humain a toujours été lié aux animaux
parce que la manière dont nous avons
avant Darwin et un petit peu après
tracer les frontières penser humanité
souvent en l'opposant à l'animalité
définie par ce que ce que de façon
privative hein donc il y a à part
Montaigne mais longtemps il y a eu ce
cette histoire de la manière dont
l'homme se présente se représente et
souvent lié a été longtemps lié à
justement une opposition à ce qui n'est
pas humain hein l'homme un animal
rationnel bon d'Aristote jusqu'à
l'exception étant le Pythagore
évidemment ceux qui étaient qui
croyaient en la transmigration des âmes
plus tard mais aussi mont à une voix
très singulière mais aujourdhui Darwin a
a a évidemment nous a replacé la
continuité du vivant et mais c'est
évidemment assez difficile de de de de
de c'est Darwin finalement n n'est pas
entré aussi profondément que cela
finalement dans nos représentation mais
je crois que euh je je crois que il y a
aussi le fait que que la manière dont
nous nous traitons les animaux on voit
bien nous sommes un peu embarqué on voit
bien que la manière dont nous traitons
les animaux euh fait qu'il y aura des
des scandales sanitaire qui vont de
toute façon rendre incontournable cette
question aussi par ce biais là alors je
crois que voilà donc mais moi je suis
assez confiante je pense que c'est un
processus qui est en marche alors et et
voilà c'est un processus qui est en
marche au niveau du public vous avez
raison moi je suis tout à fait marqué
par le fait que cette question passionne
les jeunes et passionne de plus en plus
de personnes la société civile même si
même si beaucoup de gens même quand ils
mangent leur sandwich au jambon ne
pensent pas à l'animal qui était
derrière et qui voulait vivre mais là
c'est là on a on a des questions
évidemment déjà moi je pense que si on
arrivait à à faire tout pour supprimer
cet élevage intensif contre-productif
bon ben ça serait déjà
formidable c'est
je vais oui c'est
compliqué oui juste juste un poin une
heure
réflexion je suis un
éleveur je veux dire je suis un éleveur
qui a
élevé toute sa vie des vaches des veau
des
chevaux en
liberté
je suis quelqu'un qui souffre chaque
fois qu'il entre dans un élevage de veau
en logette
ou chaque fois qu'il entre dans un
élevage porsin par l'organisation des
choses par le par le par la situation
sur kaiboti avec les
déjections au-dessous
et cependant d'abord je je respecte et
j'aime les gens qui font ça les
éleveurs et cependant je sais une chose
qui est pour cela très difficile c'est
que si je nous entrions dans un système
qui
imposait aux
autres éleveurs les règles que la vie a
fait que j'ai pu suivre moi-même pour le
le confort des animaux et en quantité et
en
prix il serait
impossible de nourrir même la France
alors je ne parle pas des 7 milliards de
personnes des 6 milliards
autres qui qu'il va falloir nourrir et
c'est pour moi une très grande
difficulté c'est d'ailleurs la même
chose pour les pour les EGM euh je
je je suis de ceux qui espèrent que nous
ne céderons pas dans la négociation
commerciale éventuelle avec les
Américains sur ce point mais je sais
aussi
que nourrir
l'humanité et par exemple faire pousser
des céréales ou du
riz en condition
semiésertique ça oblige à travailler sur
le vivant je ne dis pas que je le
souhaite mais je voudrais bien qu'on
m'explique comment on
fait je cite un exemple qui n'est pas
OGM mais qui travaille sur le vivant
euh en
1945 quand la guerre s'achève le
rendement d'un hectare de maïs chez moi
est de 15 quinau hectar en
moyenne et puis sont arrivés ceux qui
travaillaient sur le vivant et qui ont
fait non pas de la manipulation
génétique mais quelque chose qui est un
peu d'ordre semblable qui est
l'hybridation du maïs et l'hybridation
du maïs fait que aujourd'hui le
rendement moyen est de 90 qu exactement
sur les mêmes terres avec le même climat
si on narrose pas si on arrose chez moi
alors mais si
onarrose pas à 15 qu
hectar
avec la
lignée classique non hybride je rappelle
que l'hybridation entraîne le fait que
la graine n'est plus fertile donc vous
êtes obligé de racheter des semences
tous les ans hein non tout le tous les
semenciers
français le le chaque pied de maïs que
vous voyez depuis 1945 en France est un
pied hybridé dont la graine ne peut pas
être ressemée aucun c'est pas l'OGM de
monsantau c'est le tous les tous les
maïs culpteurs français et bientôt on va
hibrider le blé alors c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que le blé le maïs a des
organes mâles et des organes femelles
distincte c'est pas le cas du blé
mais à 90 qu hectar on nourrit à 15 qu
hectare on nourrit rien
euh et donc c'est pour moi enfin il me
semble qu'il y a là une tension
entre deux objectifs j'espère qu'on en
travaillant réfléchissant on va y
arriver mais ça n'est pas une question
aussi simple que celle qui sépare les
gentils des méchants c'est une question
beaucoup plus complexe parce qu'elle
touche
à au projet même de
l'humanité
hein et et bon voilà c'était la remarque
timide que je voulais faire
oui j'en ajouterai une si vous me
permettez c'est que manger de deux fois
par jour de la viande contrairement à
nos grands-parents qui n'ont mangé que
deux fois par semaine ce n'est pas
universalisable à l'échelle de la
planète pour C milliard d'indivis pas où
étaient vos grands-parents mais chez
moi nos grands-parents mangai du cochon
à midi le soir parfois le matin oui
oui et des
œufs mais c'est pas universalisable
c'est pas et et c'est un modèle qui
n'est pas universalisable qui n pas
génalisable dans mon pays au 18e siècle
et au 17e siècle dans les contrats de
travail avec les journaliers il y avait
qu'il était interdit de servir du saumon
plus de 5 jours sur 7 par semaine s'il y
avait tellement de saumon
que voilà et qu'il fallait quelquefois
servir de la viande c'est pourquoi bon
voilà ouais mais 7 milliards d'individus
qui mangent deux fois par jour la viande
quand ils le feront ou s'ils le font
c'est impossible avec une seule planète
parce que le il faut la aujourd'hui les
céréales sont utilisées pour le bétail
je connais plus les chiffres mais donc
alors que s'il y avait moins ça ça
serait beaucoup plus et des cérales qui
pourrai être utilisé en tout cas c'est
ce que disent oui non mais c'est pas
faux hein c'est bon en tout cas mais
vous avez raison il y a un dilemme il
faut prendre la mesure du dilemme pour
régler la question animale et pas
opposer les hommes et les animaux ça
c'est sûr non mais je voudrais revenir
revenir peut-être d'un mot sur la
question animale non pour dire que je
trouve que vous touchez du doigt d'abord
une question juste qui est le bien-être
animal Robert et moi nous ne cessons de
voter des des directives au Parlement
européen sur cette question mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas un sujet voilà dont
on parle beaucoup en France enfin en
général on nous reproche de voter des
directives pour le bien-être animal
parce qu'on complique la vie des
éleveurs des agriculteurs des
transporteurs enfin bon et cetera mais
je pense que vous mettez le Doig sur
quelque chose de juste qui est la
question du qualitatif ou du quantitatif
et que les questions à mon avis pour le
siècle qui vient je pense que ça va être
une des questions qui va venir pour les
décennies qui viennent et c'est vrai que
nous avons procédé uniquement par
quantitatif pour aller très très vite
jusqu'à maintenant avec élevage intensif
extensif avec toutes les terres arables
racheté dans le monde entier par tous
les grands émerg argent enfin on voit
bien ce qui se passe et en même temps
jamais il y a eu autant on va dire
d'éleveurs ou d'agriculteurs africains
qui ne peuvent pas manger et qui ne
peuvent pas se nourrir ni nourrir leur
famille parce que ils n'ont même plus on
va dire un petit morceau de terre à
cultiver et en même temps on a des
centaines de millions d'hectares qui
sont gérés d'une façon compliquée dans
le monde et moi je crois qu'il vaut
mieux du qualitatif que du quantitatif
donc cette question là elle vaudra
d'ailleurs pour les questions
d'alimentation dans les temps qui Vinent
que quelquefois il vaut mieux peut-être
manger mieux un peu plus cher un peu
moins en quantité et que peut-être on va
s'apercevoir dans les décennies qui
viennent ça va être en tous les cas je
trouve une question qui va Val qui va
être à mon avis d'actualité pas
seulement pour la question de
l'alimentation mais pour tout un série
pour toute une série de problèmes et
quand on se posera d'abord la question
de la qualité et pas de la quantité on
aura des politiques différentes sur un
grand nombre de sujet et de domaine mais
je voulais vous poser une question sur
sur ce que vous avez dit vous avez
pointé du doigt des dysfonctionnements
et je trouve très très juste sur au fond
la manière dont on gouverne un pays et
la manière dont la politique fonctionne
c'est-à-dire à court terme c'est-à-dire
alternance après alternance en ignorance
ce qui a été fait ce que les autres ont
dit en ignorance que les experts ont pu
dire de juste sur une question sensible
à un instanté en reprenant tout à zéro
vous avez parlé d'amateurisme et je
trouve que c'est absolument juste vous
avez parlé de oui ben moi je parle de la
France là et français vous avez parlé de
courttermisme et c'est vrai qu'on prend
les décisions en général pas seulement à
court terme on les prend aussi au
dernier moment c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
prévoit jamais dans notre pays il y a
aucune prise en compte de la durabilité
jamais on réfléchit pas à ce qui va se
passer à 1 an ou à 5 ans ou à 10 ans et
encore moins évidemment à 15 ou 20 ans
or c'est ça qui je pense est aussi
essentiel pour les temps que nous vivons
et vous avez conclu sur le pense par
toi-même et je suis d'accord et la
création imaginaire et on voit bien que
ça c'est un rôle qu'on donne ou que
l'individu peut prendre pour lui-même
par sa propre liberté mais au fond je
voudrais savoir pour vous quel devrait
être dans un monde idéal avec un nouveau
contrat social le rôle du politique pour
arriver à favoriser ce pense par
toi-même le rôle de l'homme politique ou
de la femme
politique ça c'est une question
difficile en tout cas
euh sans doute d'accompagner cette
transformation des passions politiques ù
c'est plus le binaire conservatiste
progressiste d'un côté droite gauche
ouais donc ça ça vous pla bien ah ben
voilà c'est première chose deuxième
chose
explicitation inviter à expliciter des
positions qui soutendent ces prises de
position idéologique ou écologique ce
qui est derrière les les les conceptions
qui qui travaillent qui qui explique des
justement des prises de position sur
l'usage des nourritures sur les terres
et cetera sur qui qui où justement on
est dans des conflits de valeur mais pas
s'ans rester au conflit de valeur moi
j'ai cette valeur et ben bien moi j'ai
cette valeur voilà pas du Christine
Boutin quoi ça ça devrait disparaître si
je peux dire au sens où non mais au sens
où là ça franchement vous aurez notre
soutien d'accord non mais cette manière
d'habiller de beaux mots
respect des opinions strictement
personnelles et qui sont des des valeurs
des déoût et des goûtsin et puis en plus
avec beaucoup d'intolérance ça c'est
quelque chose donc voilà ça ça serait
quelque chose porté et d'hypocrisie
porter cela cette en fait inciter à
l'argumentation hein donc même même
quand on est au départ on commence par
les émotions on commence par et voilà
donc ça ça serait et portter aussi une
vision Ricker dans un très beau texte
qui s'appelle utopie et idéologie
distingue l'idéologie euh dans son côté
justement adhésion polémique de l'utopie
qui a ce côté justement création
symbolique rapport symbolique réelle
création imaginaire et la politique et à
la fois je crois des choses des une
gestion technique de certaines choses
c'est aussi bah un compromis évidemment
on doit trancher par rapport en voyant
la compatibilité ou compatibilité
quelque chose de nouveau avec ce qui
existe déjà comme disait de la tour il
faut encaisser parfois certaines
nouveautés parfois on peut pas il y a
des priorités il y a des bien sûr mais
aussi avec une vision comme ça je crois
moi moi je pense que c'est c'est ça ça
ce serait et je pense que c'est les gens
l'attendent parce que les schém
binair ça dépend typiquement de
décisions qui concernent les
institutions si si on veut favoriser
l'argumentation alors il faut le la le
pluralisme reconnu au sein des
institutions c'est c'est c'est
typiquement le sujet mais pour aller
dans votre sens je voulais simplement
rappeler que dans notre projet voté il y
a quelques années notre première
proposition c'était nous inscrirons dans
la Constitution l'obligation de la
protection des générations
futures alors peut-être on aurait pu
parler aussi des autres espèces vivantes
mais bon qui veut poser une question il
on va en prendre 3 et pas plus parce
qu'il est 8h30 et vous
répondrez alors la précédente question
était masculine c'était Yann Verling
féminin oh pardon Mariel excuse-moi
excuse-moi
Mariel masculine alors oui bonjour je
sais pas qui parle dans ici ah pardon
excuse-moi euh dans votre souci de
protection animale est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas quand même aussi une certaine forme
d'élitisme j'aurais tendance à dire que
si je veux améliorer la condition
animale et que je veux aller ce soir au
restaurant la meilleure façon
d'améliorer la condition animale c'est
d'aller dans un 3 étoiles puisque pour
avoir la meilleure qualité gustative je
sais que l'animal qui va finir quand
même dans mon assiette aura été très é
finalement de la meilleure façon
possible tel le bœuf de Kobé à qui ont
fait écouter de la musique classique et
cetera mais finalement au bout du compte
quel est l'aboutissement de notre acte
c'est quand même quick euh le homard le
homard je peux très bien le mettre avant
de finir dans la casserole dans le
meilleur vivier possible mais il y a
quand même le moment où il va falloir le
plonger dans la gamelle d'eau bouillante
et est-ce qu'il n'y a pas d'ailleurs un
peu une espèce d'hypocrisie c'est-à-dire
finalement je veux améliorer la
condition animale mais je ne veux pas
voir l'acte ultime c'est-à-dire que je
veux bien être dans le TR étoiles au
Michelin je vais penser auar qui avir
été très très bien traité avant de finir
dans dans mon assiette mais quelque part
j'aimerais pas trop être dans la cuisine
en train de faire l'acte qui va me
produire un certain plaisir et je dirais
même que derrière cela est-ce qu'il y a
une solution euh individuellement
puisque vous parlez de conscience de ce
que l'on fait si vous faites votre pas
de de Nouvel An c'est vous-même qui
préparez votre Omar vous avez à la fois
le plaisir ce qui va se passer après
mais au moment où vous le plongez dans
la gamelle on peut avoir aussi
conscience de ce que l'on fait et
d'ailleurs ça pose une certaine
problématique aussi même en politique
c'est quand on fait des choix va y avoir
l'arrêt de la chaîne de causalité de
notre action on peut très bien savoir
qu'à court terme on va faire un choix
désagréable à moyen terme ça va être
plus agréable à plus long terme et
cetera et là est-ce que vous avez
puisque vous parlez de philosophie
pratique des solutions pratiques par
exemple à l'horizon auquel par exemple
on va euh faire notre choix pour de
manière pratique obtenir un résultat
donné al il y a beaucoup de questions
là-dedans je remarque encore une fois
que l'animal s'invite hein c'est quand
même alors que j'en ai finalement assez
peu parlé cette fois-ci mais bon euh
peti dans le c'est oui mais c'est non
mais c'est quand même ça s'invite plus
que l'écologie ce qui montre quand même
alors je vous rassure moi le Homar non
ni le foigas ni tout ça donc comme
disait monteig on devrait manger que les
animaux que nous avons tués et euh il
reprenait ça plus tard au moins on
saurait que la viande vient de quelque
chose et à coûé et aux bêtes et aux
hommes j'ajouteraiis ensuite élitiste
mais moi justement j'ai un point commun
avec vous c'est que je viens d'une
famille d'agriculteurs et d'éleveurs don
je crois savoir un petit peu de quoi je
parle et j'ai vu la
transformation transformation radicale
du
métier pas partout mais bon donc du coup
euh alors élitiste non qui est kidnappé
par la question animale c'est mon cas
kidnapper et bien euh bah ne mange plus
de viande que voulez-vous que je vous
dise mais en même temps ça veut pas dire
qu'au niveau politique on va imposer
cela je ve dire je crois là ce serait
vraiment je crois déjà si on peut parler
de l'amélioration de la condition
animale c'est faire en sorte que et
bien au lieu de mettre les truis
gestantes dans des cages exigus au
moment bon et bien on on les met on
respecte quand même leurs normes
éthologique le le besoin qu'elles ont
d'être ensemble et cetera au lieu voilà
il y a quand même quelque chose qu'on
peut aménager on peut améliorer et ça se
fait ça et là ça se fait ça et là faut
quand même pas non plus dresser un
portrait noir donc je vois pas trop ce
que vous appelez l'élitisme euh ensuite
non vous en plus qui est kidnappé par la
question animale c'est sûr ira beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui peut être fait en
politique et imposé aux autres euh il
n'y aa pas dans restaurant se disant
voilà ça c'est une vache qui a été tuée
mais elle a été bien vécu qui est
kidnappé par la question animale
considère la mise à mort d'un animal
comme une mise à mort comme le fait de
quelque chose qui pose un problème moral
quelque chose de non àoda
et refuse toute dénégation c'est pour ça
que c'est c'est quelque chose de violent
que d'être kidnappé par la question
animale maintenant il faut je crois on
peut le plan de la PO
et le plan de ce qui est aux frontières
vraiment là je pense qu'il faut les
séparer sinon on n pas dans une
démocratie on n pas dans le pluralisme
on est pas on devient justement un ordre
moral qu'on impose donc là voilà je
crois que voilà donc je vois pas votre
question je je comprends pas trop ce que
vous voulez me dire mais bon c'est pas
grave j'ai essayé de répondre quand même
bon ça fait un peu californien on dire
on a l'impression excusez-moi j'essaie
de de comprendre ça don donne le micro
parce qu'autrement c'est pas enregistre
c'est c'est c'est de l'humour hein je je
vous attaque pas du tout mais on a
l'impression de de se retrouver dans un
film de Woody Allen quand il part quand
il était à New York et qui va voir ses
amis sa femme à à à Los Angeles où il va
se dire je suis obligé de manger de laun
salade d'Herb et des choses comme ça
donc je voudrais pas qu'on touche on
tombe dans ce syndrome là si vous voulez
oui alors sauf que c'est ça c'est ça
j'ai l'impression que monsieur vous
j'essaie d'évoquer qui disait avec un
peu d'humour oui mais où ça commence et
où ça s'arrête si vous voulez parce que
on on a l'impression que là même manger
des fourmis ça nous c'est un péché donc
on est on est on est mal à l'aise quoi
voyez on est vraiment mal à l'aiseo au
passage il y a des restaurants
végétariens qui sont très bons
hein on en a plein à
Paris oui oui c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
mais c'est pas le propos c'était pas mon
propos du tout ici bah
j'ai j'ai j'ai eu l'impression que
c'était un peu ça ah bon bon bon bon
mais je vous en prie hein
féminin bonsoir alors moi je j'ai une
réflexion aussi à faire sur votre
discours très dense votre présentation
très dense vous parlez beaucoup du
contrat de Rousseau du contrat social et
de moi ce que j'en ma réflexion c'est de
repositionner en fin de compte l'homme
au sein de sa nature de la nature de son
environnement pensez-vous aujourd'hui
que cette prise de conscience elle sera
prise par les politiques ou est-ce
qu'elle elle viendra la naissance de
cette prise de conscience ne viendra pas
des opinions publiques de la prise de
conscience du consommateur qui fera lui
en fin de compte émerger des choses au
niveau
politique ben j'aurais plutôt tendance à
penser que c'est cela que ça vient
plutôt de ce qu'on a appelé au 19e
siècle la société civile qui a beaucoup
de créativité y compris dans les modèles
alternatifs agriculture et dans d'autres
pays que le note la permaculture
l'agroforesterie et cetera et et puis
aussi oui moi j'ai plutôt tendance à
penser mais c'est quand même bien qu'il
y ait pas trop d'écart entre justement
la société civile et l'État oui oui mais
la prise de conscience ça se fait aussi
par l'explication et par l'éducation la
formation est-ce que vous trouvez pas
enfin moi je trouve qu'aujourd'hui il y
a pas suffisamment d'éducation
d'information sur l'écologie on narrête
pas de nous en parler mais l'écologie
qu'est-ce que c'est réellement est-ce
que que on on aurait pas besoin d'une
approche comme vous le faites d'ailleurs
philosophique de l'écologie politique
dans dans un sens beaucoup plus large et
beaucoup plus vaste et puis pareil je
voulais aborder une autre chose que que
vous n'évoquez pas
c'est une question c'est la notion
d'espace la notion d'espace et de temps
tout ça c'est très bien mais ça veut
dire que c'est une prise de conscience
planétaire on peut pas imaginer que ça
ne se passe que en France ou que en
Europe ou que dans certaines pays de
monde ça pas de sens bien sûr voilà
c'était juste l'aspect réflexion merci
oui mais en fait ce que vous dites
vraiment pointe quelque chose
d'essentiel qui est l'universalisme
aujourd'hui quel universalisme
aujourd'hui
voilà VO quel comment vous dites
beaucoup mieux non non mais c'est c'est
ça et donc je crois vraiment c'est
important Robert rochfort député
européen merci donc je vais faire très
vite parce que ça tombe bien d'ailleurs
la façon dont vous terminez parce que je
trouve que un point sur lequel on ne
vous a pas relancé et qui moi m'a
beaucoup impressionné dans dans votre
exposé c'est finalement euh le parallèle
alors c'est peut-être pas le mot qui
convient que vous faites peut-être dans
ce que ce que vous appelez l'éthique de
la vulnérabilité
entre la condition animale et les
personnes en situation de dépendance
c'est ça qui me semble comment dire
extrêmement fort et euh qui en tout cas
dans les pensées je dans dans les
vulgades de pensées en tout cas
françaises c'est très très nouveau c'est
même comment dire l'inverse de ce qu'
est habituel de de de penser pour faire
simple on a souvent le sentiment que
ceux qui s'intéressent à la condition
condition animale ou ceux qui
s'intéressent aux personnes en fin de
vie ne font pas du tout partie des mêmes
corpus ni de pensants ni de militants et
et donc là vous vous faites le
rapprochement entre les deux alors je je
voulais d'abord être sûr que je me
trompais pas en en faisant cela euh
alors après évidemment ça quand on
essaie de se réapproprier donc cette euh
cette mise en commun et qu'on est un
politique c'est un peu compliqué parce
que alors je va dire avec un peu
d'humour parce que évidemment on peut
faire un peu d'humour surtout àci puis
entre nous
euh on est un peu compartimenté quand
même c'est un peu difficile de dire qu'
pas que tu es sur Internet oui mais
c'est c'est pour le dire c'est non mais
bon non mais je je le dis je le je le
dis je le dis rapidement enf c'est un
peu compliqué de dire qu'on met dans le
même bateau dans la même arche de Noé la
défense comment dire du chaton abandonné
et de la personne âgée très dépendante
euh ça là c'est c'est un petit peu alors
peut-être que vous voulez nous expliquer
qu'il y a une réponse métapolitique
peut-être à fournir par une façon de
penser l'universelle autrement enfin en
tout cas c'est c'est un peu un peu
difficile pour nous de faire le le
passage de l'un à l'autre enfin en tout
cas moi ça m'a paru très intéressant ce
que vous avez développé à cet égard
alors ce que vous dites sur le parallèle
entre les animaux et les personnes
dépendantes c'est plutôt ce parallèle
est plutôt fait par les éthiciennes du
CER qui justement insistent sur la
vulnérabilité ah ben non Carole
guiligane trantau exc-moi celles qui ont
mis au point cela et qui justement ont
une définition de la vulnérabilité comme
étant justement comme pouvant un être
qui peut être dominé or moi j'essaie de
développer une conception de la
vulnérabilité plutôt liée à la prise en
compte de la corporéité du sujet mais
effectivement là où nous rencontrons les
animaux c'est que nous avons en partage
ce corps le fait de vivre deux et cetera
d'abord besoin de nourriture et cetera
mais je dirais que c'est il est clair
qu'il y a une réflexion sur un contrat
social qui n'est pas seulement structuré
par l'avantage mutuel la symétrie et
l'égalité hein mais d'ailleurs y y
a-t-il eu un contrat social euh
concrètement lié à l'égalité les
féministes diront que l'État libéral
était faussement neutre puisque il y
avait des préférences induites des
dominations des rapports hommes-femme
qui étaient pas forcément égalitaires et
cetera donc bon mais moi c'est pas donc
ce que vous dites là c'est plutôt ce que
fait l'éthique Ducker avec lequel j'ai
quand même des points communs mais aussi
une divergence euh essentiel au sens où
moi j'ai essayé de construire un concept
un peu dur de vulnérabilité si je puis
dire et euh et que et une philosophie du
sujet et puis aussi adosser une théorie
de la justice qu'elles ne font pas
forcément euh voilà donc du coup c'est
et ce n'est pas je mettrai pas au même
plan moi je je pense pas ça je dirais
que ce qui est intéressant dans les
personnes bon situation dépendance c'est
pas seulement la question de leur
intégration même si elle est
fondamentale pour ne pas en faire des
personnes de second rang des citoyens de
second rang ce qui déjà très exigeant
c'est aussi que ça oblige à reconfigurer
des catégories de l'éthique qui sont
souvent trop épaisses comme cell
d'autonomie d'autodétermination très
importante mais épaisses trop manquant
de finesse et la question les animaux
ben il y a quand même d'abord avant tout
il y a la question de la sensibilité
c'est ça que ce qu'il y a en commun et
de manière très simple on peut tous être
d'accord carnivore et végétarien c'est
que l'animal c'est un être sensible et
que bon et en plus il y a une diversité
des animaux et que bon il peut il a des
intérêts à préserver on peut l'exploiter
mais il y a des conditions
d'exploitation qui sont plus ou moins
décentes voilà donc ça je pense qu'on
peut là arriver à un consensus alors
après vous politique vous votre rôle
difficile c'est de statuer polique il
faut dire n politique oui oui ah oui
nous oui mais nous vous hommes politiqu
mais nous politiques nous politiques
nous citoyens oui nous citoyens mais
vous politiques vous avez le rôle la
tâche de trancher c'est que parmi tout
ce qui est discuté par tout ce qui est
et d'ailleurs la différence entre le
philosophe et le politique ça c'est
vraiment lestros qui montre très bien
c'est que bon ben le philosophe il est
là pour mettre de la perplexité de
l'inquiétude politique à un moment faut
quand même trancher il faut trouver un
compromis me semble-t-il il faut bien
prendre une décision arrêz le philosophe
il est il est je dirais pas dans
l'abstraction c'est pas vrai mais il y a
il y a autre chose donc voilà donc ça
c'est donc c'est là c'est pour ça vous
parce que après
vous dis quelque fois les politiques ne
trch pas oui ça peut arriver ça arrive
oui dernière question féminine
oui il légifère quand il ne pe pas
trancher oui pour rebondir sur tout ce
qui s'est dit jusqu'à présent euh je me
demande si justement le parallèle qu'il
y a à faire entre la vulnérabilité des
personnes fortement dépendante et les
animaux ce n'est pas celle du chaton d
ou abandonné mais c'est les deux
conséquences d'une d'une nouvelle
société que dans laquelle nous vivons
les personnes dépendantes fortement leur
accroissement c'est dû à la au progrès
de la science qui a allongé la vie et
nous ne savons pas comment maintenant
gérer ce nouveau problème qui nous que
nous affrontons
et la condition animale ce n'est pas
celle du châon parce que celui-là on la
bon pas mais c'est euh les batteries
pour les poules pour et les et les euh
les truies en gestation comme vous de
dont vous parliez c'est de nouveau une
une une approche nouvelle d à une
évolution de la société et est-ce que
c'est pas là-dessus que nous devons
réfléchir pour savoir maintenant prendre
nos responsabilités et traiter ces
sujets que nous avons nous-mêmees
provoqués oui mais l'enfant le bébé
aussi indépendant et oui mais c'est pas
c'est pas un problème aujourd'hui le
l'enfant enfin il est géré il est géré
le problème de l'enfant mais je dirais
que là aussi j'ai sûrement pas répondu
de manière précise à la question
précédente c'est que ce que vous dites
là c'est la question de la dépendance
donc c'est une phase une manière de
penser la vulnérabilité comme
susceptibilité à la à la à la blessure
hein c'est ça que vous dire V nous c'est
ça là moi j'avais j'ai je me suis emparé
de ce terme en lui donnant au aussi une
force c'est-à-dire capacité à ne pas
être seulement pour soi parce que moi ce
qui m'intéressait c'était pas seulement
les personnes vulnérables bien que j'ai
par ailleurs pas mal travaillé sur les
décisions d'arrêt de traitement et sur
la fin de vie en particulier mais ce qui
m'aintéressait moi dans la vulnérabilité
c'était non seulement qu'elle a une
fonction critique la société ce qu'on
bien montré les éthiciennes du CER mais
aussi que elle elle installé au cœur du
sujet elle retournait le sujet qui était
pas seulement défini par la liberté ou
le pourçoit donc c'est ça moi qui
m'intéresse la question que vous posez
est évidemment fondamentale mais elle
est c'est une autre question je pas bord
là mais elle est évidemment fondamental
si je savais répondre à cette question
on pourrait breueter ça sera formidable
bien merci beaucoup merci
vous